bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
aujourd'hui nous tournons la dernière de
la saison mais je reviendrai
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons nous
poser des questions sur les banques
vont-elles disparaître
bonjour thomas bonjour olivier bonjour à
tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
c'est cash alors les banques vont-elles
disparaître c'est la question qu'on se
pose aujourd'hui question qui peut
paraître un peu saugrenue tente on s'est
habitué à voir les établissements
bancaires s'imposer dans notre quotidien
mais vous allez voir que certains
indicateurs sont sans appel par exemple
une banque sur trois est menacé de
disparition selon le cabinet de conseil
mckinsey alors les banques sont-elles
une espèce en voie d'extinction commence
comme traditionnellement avec le tiroir
cash d'antoine mahsas la traditionnelle
visite chez votre banquier pourrait
bientôt ne plus être d'actualité
en octobre dernier une étude réalisée
par le cabinet de conseil mckinsey
dévoilée ce chiffre une banque sur trois
en europe de l'ouest chez nous quoi et
en asie pourraient disparaître et ce
pour plusieurs raisons
les conclusions de cette étude sont état
que sur 1000 banques dans le monde
seulement 35% d'entre elles dégagent une
rentabilité et une rentabilité faible
1,6 pour cent pour 80% la rentabilité
des fonds propres est inférieur au coût
de ces mêmes fonds ce qui signifie que
lorsque les taux chutent
si georges des investisseurs et
actionnaires elle ne baisse pas les taux
bas génère également peu d'intérêt sur
les prêts ce qui est censé être la
première source de recettes des banques
enfin le bond des banques en ligne les
néo banque de lydia arrêt volutes fait
mal avec des frais bancaires moins élevé
une simplicité d'utilisation le modèle
des banques comptent entre aude agences
trop de personnel et justement des frais
bancaires en augmentation en 2020 ne
sait pas bien adaptée à l'arrivée de ces
nouveaux acteurs cela causait déjà en
avant la crise les suppressions de
postes par milliers dans les ventes et
ce qui nous attend dans les prochains
mois ne devrait pas arranger les choses
olivier une réaction à ce qu'on vient
d'entendre dans le tiroir cash écouter
sur les sur les banques
ça fait bien longtemps que quand vous
détailler le résultat d'une banque vous
constatez que la banque ne gagne pas
d'argent sur son métier traditionnel
mais gagne de l'argent uniquement sur
des opérations marche
donc si vous voulez on sait que les
opérations marché par définition c'est
quelque chose de d'exceptionnel si vous
voulez vous pouvez pas compter dessus de
façon récurrente et donc vous savez très
bien que c'est un petit peu comme si un
vous capitalise y est quand vous achetez
une action d'une banque en bourse c'est
comme si vous capitalisez le gagnant du
loto comme s'il allait gagner tous les
ans l'auto mais malheureusement non
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
et vous avez des banques qui n'ont pas
en plus qui ne se sont pas aux éau
contraire et bien au contraire qu'il
ceux qui n'ont pas réduit leur risque à
partir de 2008 qui sont aujourd'hui dans
des situations qui sont aussi risquée si
non plus restée que la veille de la
l'explosion des subprimes et donc on
sait que il va y en avoir une
qui va un jour passer à la trappe et ce
jour là ça risque d'être un massacre sur
les autres pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui les banques ont tête sont
tellement grosses sont tellement
importantes utilise tellement d'effet de
levier que elles sont toutes devenues
systémique et qu'on sait très bien que
quand il y en a une qui va sauter tout
le reste sotra et suivra on va continuer
à parler de cette potentielle
disparition des banques on reçoit
aujourd'hui notre invité stéphane dubois
membre d econoclaste bonjour stéphane
dubois merci d'être avec nous alors je
vous pose la question comme ça de but en
blanc d'abord pour commencer est ce que
les banques risquent de disparaître
bonjour merci merci pour l'invitation
bonjour olivier oui en effet olivier
l'expliquer les banques sur leur modèle
de fonctionnement et le modèle qu'elles
ont si vous vérifiez depuis 2008 ce que
disait tout à l'heure olivier c'est
qu'en fin de compte on a une crise qui a
été acquis par qui depuis a laissé prime
aux états unis qui était basé sur quoi
quelqu'un qui sait donner la possibilité
d'acheter un appartement une autre
personne qui lui a prêté à des taux
complètement stupide sans aucune
vérification même de la capacité de
remboursement de cette personne et un
jour on s'aperçoit qu'on s'amuse en plus
de ça à titriser les opérations et on
retrouve n'est plus ni moins toutes ses
tripes 6 titrisation pardon dans
l'ensemble du marché
ça s'arrête net d'un coup les banques
étaient en faillite
il a fallu les sauver alors aujourd'hui
très justement elles sont devenues
encore plus grosses elles ne se sont pas
restructurée interne en interne c'est à
dire qu'elles font toujours leurs
opérations de marché et dans
l'exposition risques et c est tellement
grand vous avez des clients de ses
propres banques qui sont pas dans des
grandes grande forme on prend airbus on
prend d'autres entreprises on nous
apprend aujourd'hui que je passe et tout
le monde se rend bien compte deux mois
on n'a pas dix 10 ans 2 mois de non
consommation mondiale tout est à l'arrêt
et les plus grands gros
s'arrête et 10 on n'a pas de trésorerie
alors pourquoi une banque disparaîtrait
pas pourquoi pas bien sûr est ce que ces
banques peuvent être impactés par
l'absence de retrait on a notamment
conseillé constaté pardon pendant le
confinement que les retraits d'argent
liquide avaient fortement chuté je vous
donne quelques chiffres moins 90 % en
espagne - 60 % en angleterre - 40 % en
irlande en france depuis le début du
confinement on est à moins 50% de
retraits dans les distributeurs
automatiques et depuis 2012 de manière
générale les opérations en espèces ont
baissé en moyenne de 2 2% par an olivier
est ce que ça participe de la mauvaise
santé des établissements bancaires
non ça c'est est ce que je sais pas si
vous le voyez venir mais là c'est gros
comme une maison s'est en fait on va
essayer de prétexter cette baisse des
retraits d'argent pour supprimer
l'argent liquide c'est le rêve
évidemment des des autorités et des
banquiers et de tout ce système
c'est de vous flic est encore un petit
peu plus c'est à dire que vous serez
obligés de payer soit avec une carte
soit avec votre téléphone et donc on
recueillera toutes les informations sur
vous et qu'on informations qu évidemment
même si neil il ya on se sent prêt sera
de revendre à au plus offrant donc il
faut pas se laisser avoir là dessus il
faut au contraire continuer à payer en
liquide et à utiliser du liquide parce
que sinon croyez moi vous serez en
prison bien plus efficacement qu'avec un
bracelet à la cheville donc le sur les
banques c'est pas c'est pas parce que
vous ne valez pas retiré quelques
quelques centaines d'euros au date d'à
côté qu' elles vont mourir c'est pas
c'est pas là tu le problème le problème
c'est que je vous ai dit il ya
énormément encore d'effet de levier il
ya énormément de créances irrécouvrables
dans l'est dans les banques de mauvaise
qualité et que
c'est donc là son âme et à un moment à
avoir des pertes qui vont largement très
largement dépassé leurs fonds propres et
que ce jour là vous utiliserez
probablement la technique du bel hymne
c'est à dire que on ira se servir sur
les comptes pour sauver la banque
c'est un modèle assez extraordinaire la
banque c'est à dire que jusqu'à
maintenant c'était privatisation des
gains et mutualisation des pertes donc
en fait c'est fâcheux gagne pile tu
perds donc c'est un modèle qui est
unique et qui est extraordinaire puisque
on peut faire toutes les bêtises du
monde et ça depuis ltcm donc ça ça date
de 98 avec monsieur greenspan qui à ce
moment là était à la tête de la banque
centrale et on a été fait à ce moment là
il ya ma banque centrale a décidé de de
garantir tous et est maintenant on a on
a des banques qui font de la voltige
mais avec un filet en dessous donc ils
savent que au pire ils seront rattrapés
et ça permet à ces banques de faire
n'importe quoi puisque de toute façon il
n'y a pas de risque au final ces
contribuables ou c'est le déposant qui
paiera stéphane dubois un mot sur les
moyens de paiement on en a parlé un
petit peu avec olivier est ce que c'est
un impact comment vous voyez cette
évolution le paiement sans contact
puis l'arrivée de nouveaux acteurs aussi
sur le marché on voit les dégâts femmes
qui sont très attentives à ce qui se
fait dans ce domaine là alors dans le
tiroir cache tout à l'heure il disait
une chose assez intéressante quand même
très intéressante même les nouvelles
banques
il ya le problème aussi réglementaire ça
on n'en parle quasiment jamais mais la
réglementation a contraint les banques à
tout un tas de systèmes de procès sept
contrôles d'équipements informatiques en
gros la transparence le blanchiment
d'argent les recueil d'informations
clients tout ça tout ça fait que ça leur
a demandé énormément d'argent à des pour
lé développement de systèmes
informatiques d essayer d équipes des
directions juridiques
et contrôler qu'ils n'avaient pas avant
et en fin de compte on s'aperçoit que on
alourdit la réglementation et ça devient
de plus en plus dur pour l'établissement
mais il faut quand même savoir vous
prenez pas rendre des comptes comme n 26
bat pour leur faire de la pub ou de
hautrage les ai pas en tête mais vous
ouvrez un compte bancaire en trois
minutes
récemment j'ai perdu ma carte bleue ma
chère banque je lui ai téléphoné ils ont
mis un mois et demi à me renvoyer un
code sms parce que leur système
d'information est tellement mal foutu
que je n'arrive pas à voir mon code sms
parce que soi disant j'ai coché quelque
chose qui m'interdit en gros si pour
vous montrer qu'ils sont pour beaucoup
des fois has been sur pas mal de points
donc à un moment donné s'ils ne se
restructure pas ça va pas le faire par
contre c'est vrai que le retrait de
l'argent obligé est tout à fait raison
mais ça on le voit venir gros comme une
maison
de toute façon je ne sais pas ce que va
penser olivier de ça mais l'aco vide va
être exclue a beaucoup de mots les états
sont aujourd'hui pardon du terme et à
poils la banque qui devrait être
capitalisée par l'état depuis la loi
sapin de ses très claire c'est non
donc qui va requis et alizée qui on a un
président de la république qui nous est
dit a pas très longtemps chez que ça te
fera sourire olivier mais je soutiendrai
tout le monde et il ya personne ne
tombera bon on peut se balader dans
paris on vous verrez un petit peu déjà
des commerces qui réouvre pas certain
qu'ils reverront jamais alors ça fera
d'autres opportunités il y aura à la
place d'une mercerie il y aura peut-être
une banque peut être un jour une petite
agence un super market ou quelque chose
comme ça mais voilà le retrait en
liquide
évidemment moins il y en aura plus ça va
faire du bien parce que vous pourrez
tous demain matin à payer avec ça et
croyez moi que vous serez fiche est
traqué il suffit aux moindres sense donc
ça ça va être assez rigolo où rien n'est
fait par contre je rappelle une petite
chose deux jours sans retirer sur un dab
c'est l'émeute
cela veut dire que si demain matin le
dab il est fermé et que vous pouvez pas
retirer d'argent liquide au bout de deux
à trois jours les gens vont commencer à
apparaître content et là ça va pas de
gilet jaune savez tout le monde levine
réaction à ce que vient de dire stéphane
dubois sur le fait que l'état ne peut
pas forcément recapitaliser les banques
on sait
je vous dis vous avez de deux choses
pour sauver une mort vous avez ce qu'on
a fait jusqu'à maintenant c'est à dire
des buy out les bailouts à consiste à
quoi en gros c'est à nationaliser la
banque
en tout cas ponctuellement et à la faire
payer par les contribuables
la perte bon ça c'est ce qu'on a fait
jusqu'à maintenant parce que je dirais
les pertes étaient à peu près
raisonnable entre guillemets ne
représentait pas 10 15 20 % du pib mais
représenté quelquefois un ou deux ou
trois pourcent du pays et donc vous
aviez cette cette technique là jusqu'à
présent ensuite on a voté la façon d'une
autre façon de faire qui est le bel
hymne et le bel hymne ça consiste en
quoi
et bien en effet vous fermez la banque
et puis vous vous servez sur ce qu'il ya
dedans mais c'est une méthode je dirais
c'est une bombe nucléaire si vous voulez
c'est à dire que vous savez que vous ne
pourrez l'utiliser qu'une fois parce que
évidemment si les gens réfléchissent
deux minutes si vous faites ça dans une
banque
et bien vous allez déclencher un bank
run dans toutes les autres ben on va se
précipiter on va vider les comptes
puisqu'on sait que la prochaine c'est la
nôtre en gros donc on sait que ça ne
servira qu une fois et et qu'on le fera
au moment où là la perte sera tellement
énorme qu'on ne pourra pas l'assumer
par un bel ajout de toute façon rappelez
vous monsieur draghi l'avait annoncé
l'avait annoncé d'ailleurs avant chypre
où le bel hymne avait été a été utilisé
il l'avait annoncé en répondant à une
question d'un journaliste où il avait
dit vous savez une fois je
évidemment je résume avec mes mots ce
n'étaient pas les siens mais c'était
presque ça une fois qu'on aura attendu
les contribuables et que vraiment il y
aura plus de poils sur la peau et bien
on sera bien obligé
d'aller taper dans les épargnants et le
journaliste lui dit mais les épargnants
monsieur draghi
c'est les déposants et monsieur draghi
lui réponds oui
donc on sait que ça va arriver il vous
l'a dit il faut les écouter quelques
fois ils disent pas que des bêtises
souvent ils en disent mais là il ya des
choses comme ça qui passe
et puis madame lagarde a pris le relais
l'a redit aussi avec ses mots à elle à
legrand risette qu'elle appelle de ses
voeux
et bien c'est ça c'est à dire qu'un jour
vous dire ah bah vous aviez vous aviez
100000 vous aviez 200 milles sur votre
compte et bien maintenant vous avez plus
de 10000 et nous on s'est servi
voilà pour sauver la banque mais en
revanche quand la banque faisait des
résultats elle vous redonnez pas de sou
enfin j'en ai pas vu beaucoup en tout
cas ont marqué dix secondes de pause
messieurs kg on continuera notre débat
sur l'avenir incertain des banques
on revient dans quelques instants de
retour dans ces caches on parle de
l'avenir des banques qui on est pour
cela avec olivier delamarche et stéphane
dubois membre d econoclaste un mot
peut-être monsieur sur les crypto
monnaie ça peut être considéré parfois
comme une menace pour les banques en
tout cas certains utilisent ses cryptes
monnaie pour s'affranchir des
établissements bancaires mais d'après la
banque des règlements internationaux 80%
des instituts monétaires réfléchissent à
un projet de monnaie numérique
l'enjeu est autant de contrer
l'émergence des crypto monnaie que
d'accompagner la disparition du cash
j'ai une question simple stéphane dubois
la crypto monnaie est ce que cela va
tuer les banques ou est-ce que cela va
sauver les banques
alors là je suis pas un fervent partisan
du sujet non là je crois que je vais pas
me faire des amis
si on base sur quoi été créé l'économie
s'est créé sur un papier qui
s'échangeait à vent contre de l'or tant
qu'on avait la même valeur d'or que le
papier le papier valait quelque chose
après on s'est mis au niveau de
bretton-woods a commencé à dire on va
imprimer plus de papier que nous avons
une valeur réserve
bon je pense que tout le monde et pas
trop stupide
alors je vais vous prendre cet exemple
un petit peu trash mais je peux le faire
parce que c'est pour mes parents ma
maman un jour m'explique me dit mais
chérie si c'est comme ça je vais aller
retirer mes billets à la banque qui
valent encore quelque chose je lis tu
sais maman sur ton étagères il n'y a pas
écrit voilà ici les 5000 euros de madame
dubois n'ont malheureusement il n'y a
pas une personne à une personne dans le
dab qui pousse les biais de la carte qui
a reconnu à l'argent ne circule pas il
n'existe pas il est numérique déjà donc
si on peut s'amuser demain à faire une
crypte monnaie mais sur une valeur de
quoi de papier qui vaut que dal
alors vous me direz il papier vaut déjà
que dalle donc si il a que la valeur de
l'encré de la valeur du papier mais faut
se dire qu'aujourd'hui à des billets qui
circulent vous en avez deux ou trois
mais en fait vous en avez 10 il y en a
deux qui ont la valeur de 10 retirer ses
shoots très bien avoir son cash dans sa
poche
mais si demain matin le billet que vous
avez vos rien vous n'avez plus rien
demain matin dans une crypte aux
monnaies pourquoi pas allons-y faisons
crypte monnaie selon le système crayon
du fantôme
pas de problème sur quelles valeurs le
problème dans ce monde aujourd'hui c'est
que ont créé une économie qui n'a zéro
valeur zéro on crée des richesses qui
n'ont pas de contre valeurs
quand vous avez un appartement il ya un
truc avec de la pierre qui est située à
un endroit qu'on connaît qu'on voit
c'est tangible entre guillemets c'est à
dire ça une valeur je n'ai pas qu'elle
peut varier pas varié par monte pas
descendre donc à un moment donné si
l'histoire de crypto monnaie moi
personnellement je sais que je vais en
faire hurler plus d'un y en a qui
soi-disant ont de l'argent aujourd'hui
un crypto mode et je le redis
transformez le en écusson et trébuchants
achetez-vous quelque chose avec
parce que demain matin on en reparlera
olivier votre avis sur sur la crypto
monnaie on a par exemple un rapport de
jp morgan sur le bitcoin qui explique
que les bitcoins se sont rarement
échangés en dessous du coût de
production y compris dans des conditions
très désordonnée on voit que certains
établissements bancaires et financiers
regardent avec attention ce qui se fait
dans ce domaine là
beaucoup de banques ont regardé avec
attention des trucs qui aujourd'hui va
le plus rien donc c'est pas je ne sais
pas parce que jpmorgan s'y intéressent
eu forcément ça veut dire que c'est le
c'est l'avenir
non enfin moi je me suis exprimé un
certain nombre de fois sur les sur le
bitcoin est sûre le crypto monnaie alors
il ya je suis d'accord avec stéphane il
ya toute la secte des beach boys qui va
nous tomber dessus là à peine l'émission
fini et comme ils ont l'habitude de le
faire simplement parce que une fois ils
ont gagné 200 balles dessus et qui se
croient depuis très intelligent mais non
enfin moi je je je vous ai toujours dit
je pense que tant qu'on ne base pas une
monnaie sûre sur quelque chose de
tangible de physique ça vaut rien alors
je dis pas que le lait monnaie actuelle
valent quelque chose elles ne valent
rien mais justement c'est pas parce que
les monnaies actuelle ne valent rien
qu'il faut aller se précipiter dans
quelque chose qui ne vaut rien non plus
en espérant que de faire le coup du
siècle donc non je ne suis pas je suis
pas pour les cryptes monnaie je ne suis
pas pour la disparition non plus de
l'argent liquide et j'aimerais bien que
on arrête ce qu'on est en train de faire
en ce moment c'est à dire de détruire
systématiquement la monnaie et
l'économie réelle au profit de du
paraître
il n'y a qu'à voir aujourd'hui les les
déclarations des banques centrales et
des politiques qui sont en campagne
en tout cas pour les états unis et qui
sont prêts à annoncer n'importe quoi
n'importe quoi en terme de création
monétaire n'importe quoi en plan daide
on vous balance des trillions de dollars
ça devient
grossesse on est on est dans un cinéma
permanent avec des gens qui se se
balancent des des sommes dont ils savent
pertinemment que ça ne ça ne veut plus
rien dire aujourd'hui
simplement parce qu'il faut essayer de
faire croire que ça va relancer quelque
chose alors qu'on sait que ça ne relance
rien que ça va maintenir les bourses en
lévitation alors qu'on sait pertinemment
aussi que sarah une fin et donc la fin
on l'attend c'est ça ça durera ce que ça
dure à peu importe mais on sait que
aujourd'hui on a complètement détruit la
valeur de la monnaie et qu' il faudra
que qu'à un moment on n'en on en prenne
acte et là ça risque d'être douloureux
ça risque d'être douloureux aussi je
vous dis sur les banques parce que
statistiquement ça ne pourra pas tenir
donc vous savez que statistiquement vous
aurez une banque en europe une banque
majeur en europe qui sautera ce jour là
eh bien on fermera toutes les banques
pour éviter un bank run généralisée et
comme le disait stéphane si vous fermez
les banques et que les gens veulent
récupérer leur argent
croyez moi au bout de quelques jours ils
vont devenir très nerveux stéphane une
dernière réaction sur ce que même dire
olivier
alors oui mais je valide le survenir sur
votre titre les banques vont-elles
disparaître je vous donne une
information à la date du mois de
décembre il y a déjà des réseaux
bancaires qui ont réfléchi à baisser
leurs coûts la caisse d'epargne par
exemple ouest feront ce côté bretagne
qui a lancé un pavé dans la marre je
pense que c'est un test
alors c'est un test oui et non puisque
ça existe déjà un petit peu
à une autre échelle c'est fermer les
agences peut-être qu'on va aller non pas
sur une disparition sèche immédiate mais
peut-être sur une restructuration de
certaines opérations alors ça veut dire
attention du chômage des mises en
situation de précarité pour certains
parce que quand vous avez été au guichet
d'une banque pendant un temps
je dis pas que vous savez rien faire 1
c'est pas le débat je vais encore me
faire engueuler c'est pas ça mais ça va
être très difficile de retrouver au même
poste dans une autre activité puisque
genre d'activité pourrait disparaître
elles sont remplacées par des réseaux
d'indépendants aujourd'hui cette banque
a annoncé qu'elle fermerait ses agences
et qu'elle proposerait à ses salariés de
devenir des ce qu'on appelle mandataire
d'indépendants d'opérations de banques
exclusif donc si la banque commençait à
dire ça je pense qu'il faut tendre
l'oreille et commencer à regarder le
sujet elle se dire attention ils sont en
train de penser à créer nouveau modèle
d' agences il ya une raison fait une
passe qu'il gagne pas d'argent mais du
tout avec le particulier et puis il
faudrait peut-être aussi arrêté moi
j'aimerais bien je fais un appel mais je
prierai lé je ne sais pas quoi
d'ailleurs
mais il serait bien qu'on ait des
émissions dans les télés nationales pour
éduquer le particulier à la finance
parce que le nombre d'émissions stérile
sur les affaires des uns et des autres
des écoutes d'un avocat de trucs d'une
liste politique qui a payé avec son
chèque professionnelle en os x ou y
raisons sont contre ballon par contre
c'est de savoir que va devenir l'
épargne du particulier comment les gens
ou vont arriver à s'en sortir expliqué
pourquoi ça va être compliqué et amener
un petit peu de transparence parce
qu'aujourd'hui on se cache derrière son
petit doigt dans un système qu'on essaye
de tenir à bout de souffle
en fait ce système il est mort mais il
est mort depuis un moment et depuis 2008
on a vu qu'il avait fait une grosse
crise cardiaque alors on l'a réanimé on
lui a mis les produits on lui a mis les
va on l'a tous fait il en train de
mourir la folle lâché faut le laisser
tomber faut créer autre chose
bon courage pour celui qui va s'y
atteler merci beaucoup stéphane dubois
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes membre d econoclaste on
continue cette émission avec l'actu de
la semaine
on passe à l'acte ou de la semaine une
actu qui date un petit peu mais dont on
voulait vous parler avec ses soupçons de
fraude géante 1,9 milliard d'euros chez
la société allemande de paiement en
ligne wirecard la fim la firme bavaroise
prestataire de services financiers a
indiqué qu'une somme de 1,9 milliard
d'euros bien qu'inscrite à son bilan
n'existait je cite très probablement pas
et depuis la société a annoncé son dépôt
de bilan olivier ce que vous avez une
réaction sur ce que certains considèrent
comme un des plus gros scandales
financiers en allemagne de ces dernières
années c'est toujours la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'au moment des crises
vous avez des cadavres qui ressort des
placards
donc quand en 2002 vous aviez eu enron
en 2008 vous avez eu madoff
et puis là vous avez ce groupe allemand
il n'y a rien d'étonnant là dedans c'est
c'est systématique
à l'occasion des crises vous dit vous
avez les les cadavres qui ressortent et
on s'aperçoit que telle ou telle société
alors pas forcément d'ailleurs de façon
c'est pas forcément une escroquerie
mais la salle est peut-être mais
c'est à ces occasions que on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya les entreprises zombies on va
dire totalement zombies merci beaucoup
olivier merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez retrouver les émissions
précédentes sur le site rtl france point
tv n'oubliez pas de poser vos questions
également dans la section commentaires
ou sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rt cash pour cette dernière
émission de la saison olivier le mot de
la fin
bonnes vacances et à bientôt pour une
troisième saison encore plus décapantes